a
[Música]
d
conozco la cura para todo el agua salada
en todas sus formas el sudor las
lágrimas el mar
esta es una frase de la escritora karen
blixen y la elegí porque quiero
contarles del poder del agua y cómo ese
poder me cambió la vida no sólo a mí a
mucha gente quién no se siente
reconfortado con sólo tomar una ducha
no estoy esperando la respuesta por si
alguno le pase lo contrario simplemente
que yo lo siento así siempre siempre me
gustó nadie desde que era muy chiquita
en el club alumni el club que era mi
patio vivía en la esquina y pasaba la
mayor parte del día en sus instalaciones
rodeada de amigos que aún conservo y de
profesores que fueron para mí
inspiradores
tengo grabada en mi piel
mi primera carrera de competición de
natación tenía absolutamente todo en
contra mis contrincantes me llevaban 3
años
cómo
medio metro dos centímetros no me sobra
así que con mucho miedo me subí a la
conejera respire hondo y me tiré al agua
y no saque la cabeza en los 25 metros
que me separaban del otro borde
toque la pared y para mi sorpresa las
otras no habían llegado había ganado esa
carrera había ganado mi primera carrera
de natación desde ese día mi entrenadora
y mis papás me apodaron motorcito y ese
es lo que yo siento todos los días que
me levanto un motor que me impulsa a
crear a creer
a ilusionarme a conectar con mis sueños
y con los sueños de los demás para poder
llevarlos al plano de la realidad
una realidad que me golpeaba pero que me
hacía fuerte al mismo tiempo me mostraba
el amor en la mejor de sus versiones fui
madre adolescente
y cuando nacía mi bebé mis padres me
regalaron un ramo de flores con una
tarjeta que decía seguir siendo hija
este vamos a ayudar a ser mamá
y así empecé a crecer
a creer en mí
y como sustento económico había empezado
a trabajar en un gimnasio estudiaba el
instructorado en técnicas de fitness
paralelamente estudiar el profesorado de
matemática nada que ver con nada pero lo
único importante era no dejar de
estudiar y poder seguir creando a mi
hijo pero poder también llenarme de
cosas que me hicieran muy feliz
con el tiempo necesite usar más las
horas del gimnasio por lo tanto el
profesorado de matemática lo dejé pero
eso me daba muchas satisfacciones ya
tenía muchos alumnos que trabajaban
conmigo y a los que quería cambiarle su
calidad de vida no sólo por la estética
yo estaba buscando algo más
y así estaba
en movimiento siempre en movimiento no
tienen una idea de estar quieta acá
cuando mi papá sufre una lesión en el
tobillo va a cirugía y le dicen que
tiene que hacer una rehabilitación
acuática
acá en casilda no existía la única
posibilidad era viajar a rosario y en
ese viaje de regreso a casa yo lo
escuchaba el cómo iba a coordinar su
rutina para poder viajar todos los días
a realizarla
entonces le dije déjame investigar un
poquito viejo
y ese desafío fue para mí una
oportunidad
un bote salvavidas
fue volver al agua a mi infancia es el
lugar en el que yo había sido tan tan
feliz porque en el agua como en la vida
nos frenan pesadas anclas nos hacemos de
flotadores nos paraliza el miedo
buscamos pasamanos para poder hacer pie
pero cuando logramos sortear esos
obstáculos
soltamos amarras y podemos empezar a
andar en la vida como pez en el agua y
fue ahí que la descubrí pero desde otro
lugar siempre la había atravesado
horizontalmente pero esta vez todo lo
que aparecía ante mí todas las
investigaciones los métodos que se
estaban investigando en el mundo era de
una gimnasia acuática vertical
eso me fascinó sentí que estaba en el
lugar indicado en el momento justo
porque no solo mi papá estaba mejorando
sino todo lo que yo estaba aprendiendo y
podía practicarlo conmigo también me
hacía bien entonces pensé si esto me
hace bien a mí le hace bien a mi papá le
va a ser bien a todo el mundo y me anime
de a poquito porque no es fácil llevar a
la gente al agua atraer a mis alumnos a
invitarlos para que prueben esta nueva
actividad
con esto no me estoy adjudicando los
descubrimientos de las propiedades del
agua por suerte de esto se ocuparon
newton arquímedes y otros iluminados que
nos allanaron el camino pero lo que sí
soy y lo digo con mucho orgullo soy una
testigo privilegiada de ver como esas
propiedades se transforman en poderes el
poder del agua
si esa que veo desarrollarse en los
bebés cuando inician sus primeros
movimientos en el útero hasta los
adultos mayores cuando recrean los suyos
muchos de los cuales ya no pueden
realizar en tierra los adultos mayores
son la población que más está conmigo en
la primer población que pude llevar al
agua casi sin condiciones no les
importaba nada solo querían sentirse
mejor volver a moverse de otra manera si
son
el aire y el agua los medios que
desafían nuestro equilibrio solo que el
agua tiene mucha más resistencia que la
tierra hay que hacer mucho más fuerza
para moverse pero evita lesiones las
previene alivia dolores entonces como no
se iban a sentir mejor las moléculas de
agua se unen entre sí por una propiedad
que se llama las viscosidad la cuestión
y la adhesión hasta la llamaron los
científicos pero yo la llamo el poder de
la unión
porque la gente que viene al agua muy
difícilmente desista
de realizar la actividad en muy poca
gente la que se va siempre se quedan se
unen entre sí arman grupos que son y que
muy fuertes
tengo horarios en los que comparten
la actividad tres generaciones con 20 30
años de diferencia sin sin ningún
problema por que rejuvenecen se sienten
ágiles se sienten hábiles
y es por eso que yo quiero destacar este
poder del agua y esos primeros pasos
experimentales
yo los di en la pileta de la casa de mis
padres para pasar a esa pileta había que
atravesar la cocina el comedor así que
mis alumnos siempre se encontraban a mis
papás desayunando almorzando o
merendando yo les quiero dedicar un
capítulo aparte porque todo ese tiempo
mi familia y mis alumnos fueron
generosos fueron unos incondicionales
conejillos de indias con todo lo que yo
les proponía
hasta que cinco o seis veranos después
porque trabajaba solamente en el verano
mi papá me sugiere supongo que también
cansado de tanto decir en su casa hace
la pileta en tu casa debo confesar que
al principio me parece una locura pero
viéndolo a la distancia yo creo que el
veía algo que yo no estaba viendo la
dimensión de lo que estaba pasando y
adivinen qué
lo hice
construir la pileta mi patio muy
precariamente no había baños no había
vestuarios
la gente se cambiado como podía porque
no importaba no les importaba lo único
que les importaba era sentirse bien y
los bien que se iban después de realizar
esta actividad y yo no les puedo
explicar cómo me sentía yo sentía que
estaba en otro planeta no podía creer no
lo puedo creer porque me pasa ahora ver
cómo entran al agua cambian sus caras se
van sin dolor
después fui mejorando esas condiciones
porque fue como magia la gente venía y
venía ieral bocaboca fue la primera
pileta privada acá en la ciudad de
casilda estaban los dos clubes pero
están en la primer pileta en una casa
entonces la gente creo que pudo soltarse
de pudores empezó a venir población que
no tenía lugar en otro lado por ejemplo
gente con sobrepeso obesos gente que
tenía la movilidad reducida entonces
todo era placer
todo era risa porque nos divertimos
mucho también
de a poquito la que le matices
le hizo una carpa con ayuda
incondicional de mi familia esa carpa me
duró poquito como el cuento de los tres
chanchitos y el lobo porque le había
hecho más o menos y una tormenta que
llegó tres techos de ese día en casilda
uno de esos fue el mío y yo vi cómo mi
carpeta se iba
y dije bueno nunca más hasta que llegue
sin embargo trabajé todo ese verano y en
abril del otro año pude volver a hacer
una carpa ahora sí mucho más fuerte y
ahora la pileta tiene vestuario tiene
calefacción tiene todo pero sobre todo
tiene la gente
tiene mis alumnos que son increíbles
pero porque se sienten bien y
compartimos esa magia ese ida y vuelta
yo les voy a contar una anécdota como
dijo mi compañero recién hay que
llenarse de anécdotas pero quiero contar
una que es muy especial ellos crearon un
rezo antes de entrar a la clase un rey
es un agradecimiento yo no lo digo como
ellos porque son lo únicos ellos cuentan
hasta tres muy fuertes uno dos tres y
dicen gracias dios mío uno dos tres
vuelven a contar y se ríen a carcajadas
pero mucho mucho tiempo porque creen en
el poder de la risa también y vuelven a
contar hasta tres y dicen gracias
gracias gracias
ellos agradecen todos los días venir al
agua y yo agradezco el trabajo soñado
que tengo el privilegio del trabajo que
tengo porque somos agua de ahí venimos y
sin ellas no podemos vivir la gota de
agua una gota de agua tiene el poder de
horadar la piedra de transformar en
planta una semilla y de la película la
forma del agua que si no la vieron se la
recomiendo recuperó una frase que es
para mí eso
hizo un total agradecimiento
incapaz de percibir tu forma te veo mi
alrededor tu presencia llena mis ojos
pone humilde a mi corazón porque estás
en todas partes
[Música]